où
[Musique]
je déteste prendre l'avion les files
d'attentes la foule il retard mesdames
et messieurs nous vous souhaitons la
bienvenue à bord de ce vol direct
new york londres vous prenez souvent
l'avion tout le temps en fait
[Musique]
on
une personne à bord menace de commettre
un meurtre toutes les 20 minutes en un
mois gaffière mans 250 millions de
dollars ne soit fait sur ce qu'on tente
comment peut-on tuer quelqu'un dans un
avion bons d'essence hier 30 ans
mesdames messieurs je vais vous demander
de mettre les mains en l'air
c'est une très mauvaise idée marchal on
a le droit de savoir ce qu'ils parlent
[ __ ] à jean marx le numéro de compte
que vous nous avez donné est à votre nom
quoi mais enfin ça n'a aucun sens
je suis sûr que c'est un piège quelque
chose nous échappe
[Musique]
le fbi à la maison blanche et interpol
confirme qu'un vol international a été
détournée par un agent de la police de
l'air avant mars nos chasseurs sont
prêts à intervenir
est ce que vous me comprenez on n'a plus
beaucoup de temps est ce que vous vous
me comprenez
oh
je n'essaie pas de détourner cet avion
j'essaie de le sauver